good evening everyone
and thank you so much for joining us for
tonight's lecture
it's really wonderful to see so many
people here tonight and while i think
we're all feeling
a little bit sad maybe not to be able to
be
like this in person i feel really happy
that we're able through this
virtual format that we've all become so
familiar with
and to be able to share these events so
widely and there are people here tonight
from
from all over the world now it's always
a great pleasure
to be able to welcome a guest speaker to
oxford even virtually
um but it's a rare pleasure indeed to be
able to welcome
four but that's what we're doing this
evening so we're joined by dr evan
zapporan
the kianan distinguished professor of
music at mit
and director of mit center for art
science and technology
by dr ian hatwick lecter in music
technology at mit
musician and composer christine
southworth and engineer dr
isabelle soon and we're going to talk
about
music and physics now there's no
question i don't think that our
interest in the connectivity between
music
and physics stretches right back to the
intellectual
intellectual foundations of human
society
two and a half thousand years ago for
example
the great pythagoras and the lea
in mathematics physics and musical
theory two
famously is reported to have said that
there is quote geometry
in the humming of the strings and music
in the spacing of the spheres or in
other words
that there's music in physics and also
physics in music and
this enduring claim sits alongside i
think a sense that exists in
every culture that there's an important
set of commonalities between our
inclinations to
make music and to do physics
and both physicists and musicians often
talk about the extent to which
they are inspired in what they do
by a sense that their discipline gives
them
a kind of connectivity with something
universal
something beyond themselves
and the 17th century astronomer johannes
kepler for example
he wrote we do not ask for what useful
purpose
the birds do sing similarly we ought not
to ask
why the human mind troubles to fathom
the secrets
of the heavens and it's easy to see
perhaps why such comparisons
are appealing we arguably make
music and make progress in physics
through the interplay
between the same three processes
intuition
creativity and knowledge and in both
disciplines
we need all three of these ingredients
but we can profitably use them in very
different
proportions so we can rely primarily on
creativity and intuition or we can take
a fundamentally
technically rooted or you might say kind
of knowledge based
approach and these different mixtures
suit the production of different kinds
of physics just as they suit the
production
of different kinds of music
and successful physical theories are
often described
using the same words that we use to
describe
successful pieces of music things like
elegant
beautiful even mesmerizing or inspiring
and although it may not be so easy to
work out why we use those descriptions
and why we
feel this way i guess that's a job for
the philosophers
it definitely has something to do with
the fact that
the universe is no more just a load of
atoms
than mala's second symphony or that
great guitar solo
in stairway to heaven is a load of notes
so today we're joined by evan
christine ian and isabel to take a
really interesting and also very
contemporary look
at physics and music making and this
lecture also represents a first
public start point in a collaborative
project that we'll be working on
together here in oxford
to look at how we can create artistic
sonic representations
virtual instruments informed by the
geometry and physics
of crystal structures and we plan to
begin
as the title of this talk suggests with
snowflakes
so on that note over to you evan
hello everyone thanks so much for being
here and thank you alexi for that
wonderful introduction
i'm going to do the juggling required to
share my screen
so um we are here as alexi mentioned as
the opening salvo for an artist's
residency with trinity college oxford
and with the physics department
and as she also told you we're planning
on having that culminate in
a new work of art which will be
a database installation slash
performance piece
based on crystal structure as she
mentioned of snowflakes
um she mentioned kepler
and that's nicely coincidentally because
uh we're tentatively calling this
project
de nives angula on the six cornered
snowflake
which is taken from kepler's treatise of
the same name
um but as she also mentioned that
project is just in the preliminary stage
and uh so we'll return to it later but i
hope that what we present
uh about a prior project will give you
some context for it and a
taste of what it's likely to be
one of the things it definitely involves
is some degree of physical proximity
of being in the same place at the same
time and obviously that's not possible
right now
so we're hoping that science works its
magic
in many ways and will be able to be
there by late spring but we'll get there
at some point and we will do this
project
right now the four of us all come to you
from the u.s
from the very cold boston area where
we are more or less orbiting around our
home base which is the massachusetts
institute of technology
so what you're hearing and seeing right
now in the background
is a short excerpt from the piece we'll
mainly be talking about today
which is a 2018 project called
arachnodrone
spiders canvas and this project is
something of an older brother
to the snowflake project we hope to be
doing so what you're looking at is a
databased
immersive audiovisual installation with
live performers
you're seeing a cube which is three
meters in dimension
it's covered with a semi-transparent
scrim and mounted on an aluminium frame
and there's video being projected onto
it from three sides
there are four operators which happen to
be the four of us myself
christine southworth isabelle sue and
ian hatwick
we're inside and we'll be telling you a
little bit why we're there
later and
as i think it's clear from the
introduction
and from what you're seeing and hearing
this was a multi-disciplinary
undertaking
somewhere in the intersection of science
and art and as alexi mentioned in her
introduction that intersection goes back
a long way
and as social media might put it that
relationship
is complicated um that would be
a long discussion possibly a series of
discussions
and probably not the discussion that we
want to have today
[Music]
lexi also mentioned pythagoras and
somehow for musicians things always go
back to pythagoras
in the 6th century bce
here he is with his disciples
multitasking
this is a 15th century woodcut
but it shows various stages of uh
figuring out things about how music
works so on the upper left you have
the legendary hammers of jubal which uh
probably didn't happen
the idea was that they were hammering on
anvils and
if we really wanted to get into it i
explain why that's probably not the way
they figured out how to tune things but
it's a good story and on the upper right
you see he's playing some kind of glass
harmonica
and comparing it to bells which have
some numbers on them of some importance
having to do with proportion
in the lower left he's playing a
monochord
which looks kind of like a hammer
dulcimer and then in the bottom right
they're playing flutes and what this is
illustrating
is the foundation for our understanding
of pitch
as frequency and of frequency
as being inversely proportional to size
so the smaller the pipe the higher the
pitch
and the same being true of the bells and
finally of musical intervals themselves
resonance chords as ratio
with low integer ratios such as the ones
shown here in this diagram
sounding quote unquote better than
higher integer ones
so uh i made a little illustration of
this just using sinusoidal waves or
digital
um imitations of sinusoidal waves so
what you're gonna hear is a perfect
fifth a perfect pythagorean fifth
that's an exact 3 2 ratio of
[Music]
frequency 600 to 400 if you count
and then i'm going to start lowering one
of the pitches
from this perfect sound
until it hits an 11 to 8 ratio
still pretty low but one that's not just
bad but was eventually regarded as being
evil
the intervallis diabolus in the middle
ages and the renaissance
and then just for the fun of it i
figured i would take it down to unison
because you hear all sorts of
interesting things as it winds its way
down
now we're entering into the critical
band where things are so close you can't
tell and then you start to hear the
actual beats
and when they hit the perfect unison
that's the end of the demo so this idea
of intervals being ratios and low
integer ratios being
uh more consonant this has really stood
the test of time
these concepts from 500 bc
feel relevant to me every single day as
a musician
literally every time i pick up my
instrument every time i tune it
every time i compose a note they are
still the underpinnings in theory and
practice
for western tuning systems which is
pretty impressive
and they play a big role in uh the
project that we
we're going to talk to you about um now
one of the reasons that it's lasted so
long as that prior illustration suggests
is that
these ideas are based on rigor they're
based on observation they're
demonstrable they're repeatable
uh that's which is to say they're based
on
some form of the scientific method
now pythagoras also projected outward
from this
uh into the heavens to the notion of the
music universalis which is
thought of as the music of the spheres
and the idea was that heavenly bodies
rotated and resonated in a way that was
absolutely in accord with those same
acoustic principles which is why this
illustration from the 17th century by
our flood
music of the spheres looks so much like
that little diagram i showed you
because these proportions were felt to
have to be the way the heavens were also
proportioned and in the same accordance
of consonants and dissonance
and you can see that kepler actually got
into the act ii in his
harmonic says mundi and actually wrote
out the scales for each planet for our
convenience
um now all this was eventually this
didn't hold up as well as the tuning
stuff did so this was all of course
disproven and superseded
but it's still a very powerful idea and
the idea of listening to the heavens
actually stays very important as those
of us who remember
the confirmation of gravity waves
from ligo in 2015 this famous chirp
i don't know if it's what pythagoras had
in mind for the music of the spheres but
i hope he would have approved
uh but what's important about this is
that what was measured was acoustic
it wasn't the music universalis that
pythagoras
thought but it was the music of the
universe and it verified scientific
theory
now three years before that famous
ripple in 2012 the mit
center for art science and technology
was launched i have the honor of being
the
inaugural faculty director of that along
with lila kinney my co-director
and we invited for our first residency
the amazing artist
scientist tomas saraceno showed here in
one of his
sculptures he came to campus numerous
times for several years and he
collaborated with several departments
including aeronautics
school of architecture and also with uh
professor marcus buehler of civil
engineering
you can see uh professor buehler on the
left
and another mit faculty member very
respected john oxendorf from the center
and tomas
on the right at a panel they did
in 2014 and from the slide behind them
you can see that they shared a great
interest in spiders and spider webs
which also played a huge role in this
project
but on that first saraceno visit in 2012
my role was basically to be his shepherd
or
sherpa schlepping him around and making
sure he got places and that also got me
the perk of being able to spend a lot of
time with him
take him to a lot of meals which were
followed by various imbibements
and at one of those meals we began
talking and tomas began talking about
how he had a dream of building a
spiderweb instrument
which the way he described it seemed to
be something like a giant trampoline
that was also kind of a drum circle
um it wasn't the details were not
particularly clear but
the idea was planted and the gist of
that idea
was that a spider's web was in fact
already something of an instrument
because it vibrates and vibration is
sound vibration is music
spider web vibrations are not perceived
by the human ear
but the human ear can hear lots of
things like gravity waves
so as tomas described it when the spider
moves around she is playing her web
she's also listening to her web not
through her ears for the simple reason
that she doesn't have ears
but through her legs another sensory
apparatus she's feeling its vibrations
she's responding so the web isn't just
her house
it's not just a trap for prey it's also
an instrument
and it's also a place to listen and what
the spider hears
or senses more properly is based not
just on what's vibrating in what way
but on her own location within the web
so please keep all of that in mind too
now a couple years later i was in berlin
i went to tomas's factory
by invitation i happened to have my bass
clarinet
and tomas took me to a room where he had
just put microphones in and around a
spider's web and he was
amplifying the spider's vibrations
through
various types of microphones and he said
oh you know she's really active today
that's very unusual maybe
you want to get your instrument out and
improvise with her
so i did uh
and there we are and uh then we released
it on a record
um now to be fair uh he was inviting a
lot of musicians
to make music with the spiders so i
wasn't the other only human on the disc
but right now this is just uh me and her
an unnamed uh serta foreign spider
now it's certainly poetic license to
think of what we're doing as an
inter-species collaboration
let alone communication but please at
least consider this
i don't know what the spider made of all
this i don't know if she was responding
to me or not
i don't know if she loved it i don't
know if she hated it i don't know if she
noticed what i was doing
but on the other hand i play music with
a lot of people
and quite honestly i don't always know
what they're thinking or what they're
feeling or if they're listening
so um in any case
back at mit i've already mentioned my
wonderful colleague marcus buehler
at that time with head of civil
engineering and as mentioned he and
tomas saraceno had bonded over spiders
which professor buehler was originally
interested in and is still interested in
for structural engineering purposes what
can be learned from the way they produce
silk
construct a web etc isabelle sue's going
to return to that point in a few minutes
but professor bueller also is something
of a polymath in fact he's a musician
himself
uh he's a great scientist artist uh
in the um in the uh in line with
albert einstein richard fine feynman and
and the like
and he uh himself began making
sonifications of materials of various
kind amino acids proteins
etc now what do i mean by this
sonification
many of you are familiar with the term
but for those of you that aren't the
simplest way to define it
is as the oral equivalent of data
visualization
translating data sets or measurements or
models into something hearable
and if you like calling it music
in a way the music universalis is a type
of theoretical sonification
and in fact it's actually just to
mention really quickly one that a lot of
musicians have tried to realize over the
years
i just threw together a few album covers
here of of
strauss walt's music of the spheres of
the great mike oldfield's music of the
spears manheim steamrollers music of the
spears coldplays music of the spheres
maybe we've had a enough music of the
spears
for a while but um again it stood the
test of time
as for marcus buehler his name may be
familiar to you because he became
something of a meme
personification this year when he
sonified the gene sequence of the covet
19 virus
which obviously elicited a lot of strong
responses that's a whole discussion in
itself
but that aside what this is is just a
really superb
example of what might think of this a
pure sonification in which
the gene sequence itself becomes a kind
of score
the researcher slash composer sets the
mapping
certainly he makes a lot of decisions
about that regarding sound and scale
but having made those decisions he just
lets the data speak
or sing for itself
you can find this on soundcloud very
easy
i don't know that there's any other
sonifications of the covid virus so
[Music]
now meanwhile sarah cena was invited to
him on a large-scale
cart blanche exhibition at the pele
tokyo wonderful
art gallery in paris and he asked me
if i could mount some kind of spider and
spider musical performance for part of
it
so i asked professor buehler if he might
have someone on his team who would be
interested in discussing this
thinking back to my conversation with
tomas about an instrument
and he told me he had this wonderful
graduate student who was working
specifically on spiders and web
construction
and this is where isabelle sue at that
time a graduate student now
dr isabelle sue comes into the picture
so without further ado
i'm going to turn the narrative over to
her please welcome dr isabelle
sue
hi thank you evan
and thank you all for coming i'm gonna
share my screen now so
uh thank you uh i'm isabelle i'm a p
i mean i'm a phd student at mit and now
i will um do a short presentation on
three-dimensional sideways and
sonification
uh so spiders are extremely abundant and
most ecosystems they
have been present for over 380 millions
of years
and they make up more than 49 000
different species so
they are the proof of evolutionary
success and they were able to survive
and prosper for so long
because of their adaptation skills for
example
spiders can spin up to seven different
type of socks it's used for different
functions
and they can build different web
architectures from simple t-webs to
a typical 2d orb webs which are composed
of strong radio threads
and accessible sticky spiral threads
they can also build complex 3d sped web
architectures such as tend to have
a rectangle web
uh so now we'll show you how to image a
3d spider web
uh to get the to understand the 3d
spiderweb architecture
to images pad library firstly to build a
spiderweb
to do that we first built the frame that
we put
into a container filled with water then
we put the spider on the frame
uh the water in the container helps the
spider from escaping uh
prevents the spider from escaping and in
this project uh we use a spider
uh searcher for our picture quality
spider to build the spider web
after a few days uh the spider has built
its web and we can place the frame
uh and the spy web on the laser scanning
machine
the laser scanning machine consists of a
high resolution camera
and a sheet laser moving along the depth
of the sidewalk
and we can obtain high resolution images
of slices of the web
illuminated by the laser
so here is a video of all the scans of
slices of the certain fragile spiderweb
uh from the top to the bottom of the
spiderweb so
this part is the tangled region of the
spiderweb
it has a complex and irregular
architecture
then we will see a very dense mesh and
that's the tenth of the spiderweb
right here then after that test widget
we will see another rectangle region
so that's a 3d spiderweb then we will
use image processing
uh algorithms to derive the
architecture of the spiderweb
this is a result of the image processing
on the spiderweb we can identify the
triangle version
the top and the bottom and the advanced
hydrogen in the middle
so complex and large data can be
difficult to visualize
finding features would require
manipulating the web model and carrying
out
a computational analysis for example uh
we need to rotate and zoom a 3d physical
model to derive its information
so adding certification to a
visualization
uh adding certification which is a
visualization a method through sound
will complement the visualization and
add another perspective for
understanding the model and natural
style webs
and this would be helpful for
identifying key spider web features
so certification is used in many
applications such as fire alarms
cardiac monitoring data exploration and
as well as
creative arts installations
certification is an excellent tool for
data exploration
as the human error is actually more
sensitive to temporal changes and
pattern identification
so which allows for the identification
of interesting data patterns and large
and complex data sets
combined with the visual representation
data certification provides a more
holistic experience of the data and can
deepen our understanding of it
especially when the data is difficult to
interpret the site only
and this is the case for the goodies by
the web
so here i present a certification of a
three-dimensional spider-web
it is an intuitive and interactive way
to manipulate data and sound
to find keys by the web features so this
is a schematic of the interactive
certification process we first load the
network data here
the 3d side web structure to the
certification model
that has been built on unity 3d a video
game engine
and which communicates with max 8
and multimedia software the user
interacts with the model by sending
comments to the mid
uh through midi messages keyboard
the computer mouse vr headset and
controllers
uh the certification model produce audio
visuals
that the user can use for data
exploration pattern recognition
and also as a creative art platform
so this is a schematic of the
solidification rules
a user enters a virtual 3ds by the web
and can control where they look at and
where they go
in particular they can change a
parameter called the hearing radius
the fibers within the field of view of
the user and within the chosen hearing
radius
will be certified which means that they
will produce sound
each certified fibers is assigned a sine
wave which
together produce a more complex timbre
we choose to assign sine waves to the
solidified fibers because of the
similarities between
hierarchical organization of silk and
music spiderweb's higher call structure
ranges from silk protein to micro
meter size fibers to centimeter scales
by the web
and in the same way music is organized
at its lower scale
in sine waves building blocks which
which then can be assembled to design
richer timbers and at its highest scale
musical composition are created
from those combination of timbers
so this is an example of the
sonification model
where the user is changing their hearing
radius
all the fibers within the field of view
and reading the hearing radius produce
sound
so here we see the pink fibers are the
sonified fibers and then
the user can control that radius and the
blue fibers are silent
[Music]
this is another example uh where the
user can change
the field of view so when we
go outside the spider web we do not hear
any fibers but when
we go back in we can hear those fibers
uh this is a demonstration of the vr
version of the sonification model
we have used this by the website uh yes
so you can change a lot of parameters
such as the hearing radius or the
frequency range
uh and then um this
uh quantification model has been used uh
for the spider's canvas our
drug project as a art and creative
platform
[Music]
thank you
so i'm going to go ahead and take over
and talk a little bit about the process
of translating the spider web
really the instrument that isabelle
created based on that one uh spiderweb
and think a little bit about how we can
use it in performance and also think a
little bit about sound design of the
instrument from a more of a musical
perspective
so i'm also thinking a lot about
sonification um
and evan mentioned uh earlier
sonification is a very powerful tool
uh we can use our auditory channel in a
very different way than our visual
channel to identify patterns and
temporal structures
that might not be as visually
perceptible as they are auditorily
perceptible
and so for all of us the idea that the
spider web is a source of data
that's really interesting and complex
and is sort of the raw material for the
performance you would create it was
really
important to honor that and to respect
that but at the same time
as a composer and a musician and
somebody who creates instrument
instruments i'm thinking for myself how
can i use this web and play this web in
a musical way to create a musical
performance
um in the performance isabel and evan
i'm sorry christine and evan are
improvising uh on their instruments and
isabelle is guiding our journey
through the spider web and so as a
musician i'm wanting the spider web
to list i'm listening to evan and to
christine and
looking at where we're going and i'm
trying to shape the sound of the web to
be an appropriate sort of musical
uh structure musical composition in real
time
so for me the spiderweb actually
ultimately was a complex data set it was
like raw material that i was sculpting
to make the sound that you would
actually hear in a performance itself
and one of the key elements sort of the
key structure of the spiderweb
is this frequency this sort of
collection of frequencies this dense web
of frequencies which represent the
structure of the sound
and the frequencies are as isabelle
mentioned directly related to the length
of each
individual spider web strand now the
length of the strider web strands is in
meters so it's an absolute length of the
strands
but we need to map those lengths to
frequencies
and this is a typical process anytime
you want to take a data set and
translate it into sound
you have to think about you know what
can we perceive the sound and so the
human range of perception from 20 hertz
to 20 000 kilohertz anything within that
range
you know especially maybe not all the
way up at 20 kilohertz but we'll be able
to hear as sound and so
we took the physical length of the
strings and instead of using them as
absolute measurements we created
a set of ratios where the length of the
frequency of each string
is uh a ratio to their frequency
variable string based upon the ratio of
their physical lengths
um isabelle created a bunch of
functionality within her model to be
able to do this and to be able to shape
the way in which the lengths of the
strings are mapped onto frequencies
in particular you could define what the
frequency range of the spider web is
like what's the frequency of the longest
strand versus what's the frequency of
the shortest strand the shortest strand
is going to be the highest frequency the
longest trend is going to be
the lowest frequency and so by default
20 to 20 kilohertz would be sort of like
the standard range
but you could also constrain it by
bringing the higher stringency down
now when you do this you're actually
changing the frequencies of the strand
right you're straining differences of
all of the strands because all the
strands are a ratio applied
to this lowest to highest frequency
range so it's actually a very dramatic
effect
and it's not a very natural thing so the
spider web is a physical phenomena in
the world
we want to honor this sort of like
physical instantiation of the spider web
and the vibrations of it
but if you go out in the world and you
tap on a physical object and sort of
excite it
you'll hear the frequencies of that
object but you won't be able to
change the frequencies of the object
without changing its size something you
can't do in the physical world you're
not often going to be
changing the size of a piece of metal as
you're playing it to change the
frequency components within that piece
of metal
and the same is true for a spider web so
i was very careful not to
change the frequencies of the spider web
all of the time it's a very dramatic
musical effect too it's very visible or
very audible and very sort of um a
little bit heavy-handed to constantly be
changing the frequency of the web
um but one thing that i would do is i
would try to think about how
how dense first of all the sound she
needs to be and also what frequency
range does the
frequencies of the web want to be
distributed across if the frequencies of
the web attribute across the whole
frequency spectrum then it's too much
information
and there's not a lot of room in there
for evan and christine to play
so if i can constrain that frequency
range of the spider web to a smaller
range
then that sort of creates more space and
i can also create variations in the
frequency range
to sort of create variations in the
musical performance and i would do um
control the frequencies of the web in a
couple of ways one is
i wouldn't change the maximum frequency
of the web but i would change the
minimum frequency of the web
so i would constrain the frequencies of
the web between you know an arbitrary
minimum point
and 10 000 hertz was sort of my maximum
that i always used
and what this does is it changes the
frequencies of all of the strands
in real time as i change that minimum
frequency again a very dramatic effect
to do that but it allows me to sort of
uh
thin out the sounds there's only higher
frequencies and kind of creates more of
a crystalline effect
and then occasionally bring the
frequency all the way down to the full
frequency range of the web
be audible but then to remove some of
the higher frequencies i would use a
standard electronic effect which is a
low-pass filter
now the low-pass filter will attenuate
the frequencies of the higher
um higher strands the higher frequencies
it'll attenuate their amplitude so you
won't hear them
and it'll only let the lower frequencies
pass through the filter
and i can change the frequency of that
low-pass filter in real time too
and the nice thing about that it's not
changing the frequencies of the web
anymore it's just
changing which ones you're listening to
is changing the amplitudes and so it's a
more subtle effect than something that
you can play with to create subtle
variations without being so dramatic
something else we thought a lot about is
that in terms of music
um in the physical world if you go to go
to a random object and strike it it's
going to have a lot of frequencies
present
especially like a big sheet of metal for
example you go hit a big piece of metal
you can hear a very dense
uh uh very dense sound with lots of
frequency components
but when you think about music we often
think about pitched sounds and pitched
sounds
uh have frequency components that are
organized a little bit more
uh originally so a pitched sound
generally have frequency components that
are integer multiples
of what we call the fundamental which is
that's lowest frequency
component of an object so when you play
a piano string
there's a fundamental frequency and then
there's a lot of frequencies in addition
to that lowest frequency
but they're all integer multiples of
that fundamental
and so this idea of kind of quantizing
frequencies
to be all integer multiples of the
lowest frequency was something that we
found to be very useful and sort of a
nice way to bring this sound
from the kind of dense very cr very um
clustery sort of
sound of the raw frequencies of the web
and then quantize them into more musical
ratios and more musical
um more musical uh combinations and so
we would call this uh
making a just intonation like setting a
base uh frequency and then everything
else
is all the other frequencies are related
to themselves by some ratio based on
that lowest frequency
um or to think about like like um
uh imposing a harmonic structure on the
web
so um so this is sort of one way again
if i impose a harmonic structure on the
web and i say this minimum frequency is
100 hertz
every frequency you listen to is going
to be some multiple of 100 100 200 300
400
500 and by imposing that minimum
frequency i'm also reducing the
complexity because you can't have
a hundred you know lots and lots of
different frequencies they're all only
those integer multiples
and again sort of like thinning out the
texture of the web a little bit making a
little bit
less less dense and less kind of
dissonant
and bringing a sense of consonants to it
now if you
just if you use a very low frequency
like one or two hertz
you can simplify the the frequency
spectrum
without losing that density but as the
lowest frequency sort of
keeps ascending you're going to get
fewer and fewer frequency components as
they start to overlap
until you get up to 100 hertz and that
actually like limits the number of
frequencies in the web quite a bit
actually becomes quite um
quite sparse um
so one of the consequences though of
doing this now we're using a digital
system in a digital model so it's very
easy to quantize things precisely
but it turns out that actually in the
acoustic world precise
integer ratios are not very common in a
guitar string for example when you pluck
it
you're going to get all of these
harmonics that are integer multiples of
the fundamental
but actually the material of the guitar
string has imperfections in it and the
physical movement of the guitar string
also
has uh an impact on the actual physical
frequency content of that strength
you'll
get small deviations in the frequency of
the harmonics and this is normal for us
this is part of the characteristic of
physical sound
that you're not going to get perfectly
in tune um
harmonics but in a digital system it's
possible to get perfectly in tune
harmonics
and so this is something else that i
could play around with as a performer
i could say do i want a little bit of
detuning so a little bit of warmth we
often call it in electronic music where
we kind of warm things up by preventing
things from being originally in tune
and give them a small amount of tuning
variation around sort of those integer
multiples of the fundamental
and that was a really important uh
component and then one of the other
things i would frequently do
again for a musical effect uh more than
just representing the
using the data as a raw the spiders web
as a raw data source
is to add what we call sub harmonics so
as an electronic musician
we have these powerful speaker systems
with subwoofers that can generate these
low frequencies which are really fun and
exciting to play with
and so i would add sub-harmonics i would
take a look at the
the frequencies that we're currently
listening to from the web and i would
choose the lowest frequencies and then i
would create sub harmonics which are
integer divisions
of those frequencies so if the lowest
frequency is 100 hertz
i might make a cell harmonic that's half
of 100 or 50
or a third of 100 or 33 or fourth of a
hundred or twenty five hertz
so adding those sub harmonics is another
fun way to sort of
uh create a richer bass low frequency
bass for the sound
um but that's all sort of thinking about
the spider web material as
the frequency of the spider web as that
original complex data source and just
thinking about changing it
and sort of manipulating in different
ways while trying to preserve
the sonic structure of it and one other
element that i did think a lot about
when i was designing the system
is temporal element so the spider web
itself
it doesn't isn't really temporal it's a
fixed form
and uh we do move through the spider web
and we're changing what we're looking at
as we're moving through the spider web
but the idea is that as we're looking at
it the thing we're looking at itself is
static
you know so um so we're not moving
through the web and sort of looking
through the web as a performative
element we're sort of looking through
exploring an environment but as a
performer i wanted to add some temporal
variations
to sort of uh create another level of
interest which is really
not based on the spider web itself it's
really an imposition of
me onto the spider web and because i
wanted to reserve the
source and the quality of the spider web
itself i actually tried to have a very
minimal
amount of sort of temporal information
superimposed on it but i did do a lot of
what we call amplitude modulation
which is varying the amplitude of the
spider web
you know either very slowly or sometimes
really fast
so you can kind of hear the amplitude of
it changing and then also adding
a couple of other elements of reverbs
and delays
so here just quickly this is a
[Music]
image which sort of just talks about how
the frequencies that are
created uh by the spider web are
processed to generate the final
frequencies that you listen to
so we get the frequencies of the actual
spider web itself
and then we can round them which is that
process of quantization and then we can
add sub-harmonics to them and then send
them out as an audio signal
and then uh here i would take that audio
signal and i would process it
through sort of some very standard
electronic processes
to change the sound we can filter out
those higher frequencies
we can add reverb and delay which are
standard processes and then add some of
that amplitude modulation
and then spatialize the sound
appropriately like isabel was saying so
you can hear
the webs to the left on your left the
webs to the right on your right and the
ones in the middle in front of you
so with that i'm going to hand off to
christine to talk a little bit more
about it
hi there i'm christine southworth i am a
composer and multimedia artist
and joined this project after isabel and
evan have been working on the model in
unity and the start of the sonification
component
i'm not sure if i'm on the screen but
in any case you can hear me i think um i
play guitar
in the performances and i designed the
set and videos for this project
um so the concept as every
spiderweb is unique like no two
snowflakes are exactly the same
each performance comes out of the exact
same elements
but is completely unique uh when we were
designing arachne drone spider's canvas
we began by thinking about
the spider's web as her canvas we were
premiering the piece at the pallada
tokyo in paris
and the literal translation from tual
garenier
french for spiders web is the canvas of
the spider
our concept then evolved into thinking
of her canvas becoming our canvas
each we'd be able to create our own
music upon
her canvas um so we explore the web
sonically from the point of view of the
spider
and i wanted the performers and the
audience to feel that
experientially this would involve
creating a three-dimensional space on
which we could project the model
the original design was a pyramid that i
built in my living room
using telescoping coals and shark tooth
scrim
i cut and sewed velcro onto the scrim
panels and mounted them on the poles
this concept then evolved into the cube
that we used today
influenced by tomas saraseno and his
spider webs
which are built in empty metal tubes and
here is a photo of one of them now
in saracino's work he places different
species of spiders inside each
cube sequentially to create
multi-species webs
this is one of his webs that was on
display in paris
in our work i chose to combine our
virtual spiders web modeled from a
single tropical tent web spider
as isabelle described with photographic
images of local spider webs
from both massachusetts and northern
england
a combination of these elements is what
is projected on our cube as we perform
and here are a few of those images now
so you can see these images if you watch
the performance
we'll have one tomorrow but i do have a
couple excerpts
now this is one from one of our
performances at mit in february of 2019.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so um yeah that's um that's one of the
performances we had that
a part of it that i i really liked so i
just wanted to share that um
so as you can see we're sitting inside
of the projection cube
and just as our spider sat inside of her
cube
and we're for performance performers as
part of the visual design for the piece
i wanted to present
us as four parts of the same performer
um
with our eight hands combined the
suggestion of us
being a spider was very appealing so we
sit inside the cube facing outwards from
the center creating a single
multi-organism performer if you will as
isabel drives through the web
we hear part of the web that we're
looking at interpreted by ian
and then evan and i respond to that on
our instruments ewe
which is an electronic wind instrument
and my electric guitar with ebo
which is a magnetic plectrum um
we layer on her web as saraceno's
spiders layered
on other spiders webs uh here's one more
excerpt from another mit performance
uh you can see through the front of the
cube
through the scrim actually where ian
[Music]
[Music]
um so i'm just seeing a um question come
in here
um about is there anything rehearsed
about the music or is it totally random
and are there rules guiding the
interaction between the musicians
um and the thing is so okay it is
rehearsed we do rehearse
um and we play it together we've played
um
a bunch of times and we had actually uh
an interesting
residency at mit nano a new building
that had just um
had just gone up in the spring of let's
see that would have been 2019
and what we are trying to do with this
is to give ourselves a visual and
um musical sort of world
that we can work inside of to
create different music every time but
within the same confines so we're using
the
elements the same elements every time to
start um
but where it goes is different every
time so it's
a combination of improvised but using um
the same elements basically we have our
virtual and sonic representations of our
spiderweb
um we have the photographs of the other
spiderwebs and some videos from other
spiderwebs
um and then software and two musical
instruments and each
performance becomes unique from every
other
um i hope that that we can get back to
that in a bit when we take questions
and now back to evan
i always find the spiders to be a hard
act to follow so i i
in the interest of i have a few like
lofty concluding words but i think it
would be
really better to um to go to questions
now
so maybe lexi wants to guide us through
that
yeah absolutely let's make a start so
perhaps
we should start so i'm going to try and
take some of the questions in groups
um so there are a few questions here
that relate
to this question of whether there are
scientific advantages
so we have from raphing here what the
advantages of displaying the data is
sound inside the human range versus
other sensors such as light
i'm going to add in some more here one
from uh pat ridley is isabelle able to
give an example of how the certification
of the web helped in understanding its
physical properties
um one from um akash is solidifying
spiderwebs aimed at answering a
scientific question is it just being
done for fun
and there are a few more as well both
all sort of on the same theme of how the
science
interacts with the music so maybe do you
want to say something about that first
step and then perhaps isabel
uh could chip in too yes absolutely um
so yeah of course this piece
arachnodrome
spider's canvas is not itself science
it's it's a work of art
that's influenced by scientific research
and i i do want to say i mean i think
these are the questions that come up
and you know isabelle can address them
more specifically but
she's also addressed them in the various
research papers that she's co-authored
based on her spider web research but i
think just to
stick to the art part of it for a second
before i let her answer those
questions about the scientific value i
will say that
the musical value is not that it
allows us to see what a spider sees or
feel
or maybe in any specific way to
understand what a what the world of the
spider is like
but it does make us make music
in a different way and i have to tell
you that that's a really astonishing
thing
for for myself and i think for uh for
ian and christine also because
i mean i've been making music since
before i could talk really
and this project really took me out of
my comfort zone and made me think about
what i was doing in a different way and
when i'm playing the piece
i feel like i'm experiencing things in a
different way and and for an artist
that's hugely valuable so um
with that i'll i'll let isabel answer
the actual uh research scientific
questions
so isabelle uh yes uh so
the way the sonification model is set up
is
uh if a fiber is very short it will have
a high pitch
and if the fiber is very long it will
have a
low pitch just like a heart so
using uh the certification model you can
find the here the different length of
the fiber so you
it describes the fiber length
distribution and you can also
find the cyber uh quantity distribution
so if
the sound is very dense it will have a
lot of fibers
and if uh there's like very like not
many sounds
um that many a simple temper
it will have uh fewer fibers so it's a
way to
find the fiber and distribution and
fiber distribution as well
yes yeah so i think that
one of the ways i imagine you would use
this isabelle as a sonification tool
would be imagining that you're
controlling the viewpoint of the player
and so if you can control the viewpoint
of the player you have the agency to
look around
and experience the different qualities
of the spiderweb depending on where you
are and where you're looking
right and so that as a as a scientist
you know you have access that
information and you have the agency
as a performance the performer the
audience doesn't have that agency
right and uh and even you know for
myself you know i'm not controlling the
movement through the spiderweb so i
don't have that agency either so it's a
very different kind of a thing we're not
necessarily expecting that people will
walk away from the
performance with an understanding of
what the density of the spider web based
on the sonification
but as a tool towards a scientist i can
see that could be very useful
is that something that you you would do
is about would you sort of like wander
through the web and sort of listen to it
so to get an
understanding of the structure yes
uh so you would wander the web and then
find the location of higher
higher density and then after that you
can use your eyes
to like look into it with more details
the joystick sound you can find the
location
uh faster
i mean for me this is one of the most
exciting kind of potentialities of a
project like this that interplay between
being able to
actually um being made conscious of the
things that perhaps
are easy to interpret uh
through the sound that they make rather
than through some kind of visual
sifting process it's actually not super
obvious to me at least
with what those things are but it is
clear that there will be
certain elements uh or certain aspects
of physical systems this is true for and
that's very interesting to explore
and so being able to you know through
this artistic representation
actually um find new ways
to better analyze better uh explore
these systems ourselves as
a scientist so actually in that vein
i'll i'll pick up a couple of uh again
allied questions together so noah
um here is asking the webs remind me of
large-scale maps of the universe
showing galactic superclusters has this
been sonified
we've also had another question um so
somebody is asking down here we had a
nice question about
um what is uh yeah
it's sort of from philip whitehead here
um
what about other cross species music um
what about whales ants birds etc
and there are some others as well i
think that um you know i don't know if
anyone wants to chip in with anything
specific but what i
my understanding is that the headline
here is that yeah absolutely uh you know
there are lots of opportunities here
i um worked extensively with honeybees
um
actually and uh did a 25-minute string
quartet
with the recordings um so that
they weren't playing with us but um as a
beekeeper and
many of you might be beekeepers in the
audience here i'm not sure
um bees when they're happy sing
almost a perfect a so if you put your
head up to the hive
and they're at a nice a hum
they're happy bees and then if you hear
the
pitch rise they're not happy bees and
you probably want to go away or
get your smoker before you go into the
hive um but i recorded
my own bees and used that in the piece
and then we also did some live
performances
with bees um which is not um
recommended i guess but we ended up
putting them outside and skyping them in
which this was about 20 years ago
it's very modern before zoom yeah we
could skype these in
we've also i've worked with lemurs also
um
they were that was more uh they were
more involved
than the bees were no that's wonderful
so actually i think that that
indeed answers some of um the the
western
so somebody has asked are there certain
species known to respond to music do
those species have similar
um brain structures i guess you know um
the brain structures is quite a
technical question but essentially what
you're saying here is that there are
there are some interesting um species
specific
uh questions issues here um okay
so um loads of interesting questions
here
um so okay so somebody asks here so
cliff inman is asking so music is the
art of blending harmonically with others
these experiments to
appear to generate random sounds okay
so essentially here asking the question
is this music
i think this is a really interesting a
really interesting question it's
obviously sort of partly subjective
does does anyone evan christine uh ian
isabel would would someone like to chip
in on that
well uh we actually like the music
so this has come up before actually when
uh
you know we've done some performances
where i thought well that really ended
up being like quite beautiful and then
uh
you know uh somebody will comment on it
and go like what you've really found you
know some of the
you know the hidden complexity or the
hidden you know kind of uh
pathos of you know something very
different than what what we thought we
were doing
so i i think that uh
there's i noticed in the question that
christine answered that the question was
posed and it was up
a very interesting question but the way
it was phrased was
is what you're doing rehearsed or is it
random and i think
the for for most musicians there's a
huge
continuum between the rehearsed and the
random
and depending on the idiom right i mean
even if you're playing completely
notated music you're interpreting it but
if you're playing jazz or if you're
doing indian raga or any
number of impropository traditions
you're you're setting up rules and
you're improvising within that
so in this piece we've set up a
different type of set of rules where
it's not always humans who are
controlling i mean it's obviously isabel
or ian
but isabel is completely subject to the
way the spider built her web
so the only instrument she can play is
the instrument that the spider built now
granted
she tuned it in mixed it
but she's playing that instrument and
i guess the thing i want to say about
that is that um
you know this project has made me think
about
the nature of structure in a different
way and the nature of exploring
structure in a different way because
one of the things about a lot of the
other sonifications including
professor buehler's which i quite like
is that it takes
a material structure and it kind of
projects it out
onto the time domain as if the structure
of say a virus
right of the gene sequence of a virus or
of the universe or whatever
is somehow a hidden score a hidden
composition that's waiting to be played
but there's another type of structure
that's very important in music and it's
not and that
that is the structure of space as space
not astral space or molecular space but
um
the design of an instrument is
structuring a space it's structuring
materials
in a certain way a violin is taking
certain materials that have certain
properties
and you know encasing space in that
in those violins and in a great concert
hall or a gothic cathedral is also that
and so a great violin or great concert
hall
exists to reveal something hidden but it
reveals something in two directions it
reveals
the artistry of the performer but the
performer
also reveals something about the space
the sound of the violin the sound of the
hall so
i don't think of that as random i do
think of it as sometimes
uncertain and sometimes you find out
things you're not quite sure what they
are
and you have to figure out how you're
going to respond to them but
to me that's that's what makes it an
interesting adventure
uh hopefully it sounds appealing
or interesting to people that listen to
it um
but uh but that's the way i see it
will say you know for me as an
electronic musician
i look back on my experience as an
acoustic musician working with sound
of the physical world is so complex and
working with an acoustic instrument is a
very complex system and you're exploring
that system constantly and a good
musician
has a very nuanced understanding of the
properties of that system
but when we translate this into
something like the spider web the spider
web's a very complex system that i don't
really
is more complex maybe than i can
conceptually understand
and that's part of the joy of it right
is exploring it and
and and listening to what arises out of
it but then also reacting to it
you know on a moment-by-moment basis
kind of listening very carefully and
being
you know like not uh harmonically in
tune but sort of spiritually in tune or
sort of you know cognitively in tune
with sort of what it's generating versus
you know what where sort of our
collective musical improvisation is
taking us and constantly sort of making
adjustments and movements and thinking
about
you know how can we sort of nuance this
and massage this to get where we want to
go as
a performing ensemble this to me feels a
very natural process
you know it feels very like playing with
the web has a very strong presence
which inspires us to think about things
differently like evan was saying
you know and create a piece of music
that is based on that but we're we're
always interpreting it very heavily
based on our experience and where what
we're trying to do musically
oh great thanks so much yeah i mean i
think you know just picking up on some
of the points that
uh you've made there and they're linked
to the questions that people are asking
it really feels to me as though one of
the really exciting things here is the
ability to
uh to actually go out in search of
sort of beauty in that complexity you
know very often you know as a physicist
we work with systems that are incredibly
complex just like the web
we know if we zoom in on certain
structures we can really appreciate them
for what they are you know these
incredibly intricate
often beautifully symmetric interesting
structures but when they're crammed
together
in something much bigger it's very often
hard to uh you know to kind of pinpoint
those or make sense of the whole
and this navigation through the web
through this sort of complex structure
really resonates with that kind of
uh that kind of process great so
um one for isabel here a little bit more
specific
so kate here is curious about whether
the species of the spider changes the
web and therefore the sound that's made
is this difference easily noticed or
quite vague so are we dealing with big
differences in the natural world here or
or subtle ones oh yeah different
species would build different type of
spider webs so the one we use
is a certified citric oil so they do a
tent but there's a different many other
fiber
spiders that do like orb webs and
cobwebs so it would depend on the
species
yeah um there was another question
um yes so so um also
relating to the spiders here let's just
um
take a look here um
okay yeah so another um so somebody has
commented that the spider weber so
spider silk
is becoming um increasingly attractive
in structural design you know do you do
you think there's a future to this so
presumably your work is
is quite closely related to this kind of
idea is that right
uh yeah so silke is very strong and it's
extensible that's why it has been like
uh
it has enfire many applications in like
biomedicine
and uh structural design
uh so yes so silk is very attractive but
then what is also attractive is the
larger scale of silk which is the large
spider webs
because uh spiders have been able to
optimize those structures for millions
of years
and they're doing something right so
that's why we want to study them
okay great and then a couple of
questions sort of taking us back to that
interface
and so a couple of people richard
thompson here and martha have asked
you know what what about doing this in
reverse
so is there something interesting about
uh taking music and turning it into
spider webs
um is there something maybe that we can
so i'm now adding this glass myself you
know is there something that we can
learn from the creative process that
you've been through
uh that uh that might make it
interesting to to invert this whole
process
well i love that uh that sounds sorry
okay
uh you want to take this or okay okay uh
i think it's perfect
uh that's something we've been very
interested about so you can
take any type of music and transform it
into a sideways that would really depend
on the sonification rules you decide on
so
for our case the rules we set up
do not do reverse but if you change the
rules so that
you can do reverse modification but yeah
you can probably do a spiderweb
and i will say also uh isabelle is being
a little bit modest but in her lab
there the lab she just completed her
research in
uh they have been doing reverse
sonifications actually with proteins
so they would wait they would sonify
protein they i don't know that they were
doing it with webs but with
with other uh materials they would
sonify proteins
and then they'd tweak the music and then
send it out and have the proteins made
so um i'd love to do it with spider webs
or with snowflakes
i know there have been some people who
have been uh who've been
just taking music and using 3d printers
to generate physical representations of
a performance or of a piece
um so i don't think there was a band
that was doing that for a while they
were on tour and every tour would
end up with a 3d model of the
performance
arranged as you know probably over time
in some kind of cube format and then
you're in the audience you would get one
at the end of the night to take home
with you
oh that's great okay so um
as somebody has commented you know if uh
so pat ridley here says it'd be really
wonderful if the sonification of a
crystal structure were able to help
identify its symmetry group
so just to say this is exactly this is
one of the things
um that has uh was right at the genesis
of the uh
of the project that we are starting um
personally
personally
very interested in this question of
whether um you know it's possible to
hear the difference between a cubic
structure hexagonal structure etc
and and then building on that you know
what sort of subtleties
uh we can we're able to sort of physical
subtleties we're able to
uh to pull out from listening to the
noises that these structures make but
also by doing
creative things uh creative things with
them
um so i'm slightly conscious of the
time um panelists are there any other
points that you would like to pick up on
i'm i'm
sorry that we've got an awful lot of
questions here i've tried to sort of
consolidate them into themes
um but does anyone uh is there anything
that anyone would like to add
um before we wrap things up
so you're watching all the panelists now
stare at the uh the screen here
well there's the jackson pollock
question
um which that could be interesting
yeah okay so uh
could you set a jackson pollock painting
to music
in a similar way so i'll explain for
those who might not be familiar
uh so a jackson pollock painting is as
sort of these were made big canvases
or pieces of sort of wood
onto which paint from paint brushes was
drizzled
in repeatedly many many layers so these
are
two-dimensional artworks that kind of
have a spider web light quality i guess
um um the interesting i mean
the spider web was an a
a very appealing thing to to use is
because it's it's strings and they have
lengths and there i saw another question
somewhere in here
about um how i
i'm not sure exactly what it was asking
but so if you because the strings all do
have different lengths we did
map those so the sounds that you're
hearing are
like actually a mapping from the actual
lengths of the strings i'm not sure if
that was if any of us made that clear
but so the pitches are directly related
to the lengths of each piece of silk
and then there was something else about
um
us could we use a different we so we're
only using this single web in this
particular project that performance
which we've performed several times well
we're actually using a small
fraction of that web quite honestly
um and i still don't know that we've
explored all of it
right yeah i think if i remember
correctly it was just that the entire
web is way too much data to work with
right and so we had to constrict
ourselves
i mean just the jackson paul the
question
oh sorry i would say the jackson pollock
question kind of raises this question
around natural systems and
solidification and
you know this idea that the spider web
is a one beautiful artifact
of the natural world but we are
encountered with
you know systems like this where there's
repeating patterns that are constantly
changing and have so much complexity and
uh and they're just beautiful to to to
visually see and so this idea of all
really exploring these things in this
sonified way is just another way of
experiencing that same kind of wonder
struck at the inherent structure and
also the inherent
randomness the inherence or complexity
of things that arrive
organically so i think that that you
know the natural world
has so many interesting um it's such a
fertile ground for this
a jackson pollock painting isn't another
thing because he's organized it somewhat
aesthetically on his own structures
we're getting a different kind of
aesthetics from a jackson hollow
painting then we will from a
field of wildflowers or a spider web or
any or the
structure of the universe for example
can i uh pick up on that a little bit
just for a minute um so i also
some one of the prior questions was
asking if people have
have sonified maps of the universe
and i i guess the answer without knowing
specifically who
is yes because people are sonifying
everything but one thing i want to say
about sonification
whether it's of the natural world or of
a jackson pollock is that
you cannot leave out the amount of human
choice that goes into
sonifying and this is something i
mentioned in talking about
earlier sonifications uh and
i i was thinking about in particular
because another colleague of ian's in
mine
jesse taylor who's in physics actually
sent me recently a sonification of the
i will mispronounce this and i have no
idea what it is the
daimuan invariant spectrum
and uh you know was really excited and
sent me
all the vibrations of of uh
you know edda omega and phi and epsilon
1s and upsilon 2s
etc and uh and various diagrams
and and then various sonifications all
of which sounded very different because
as soon as you sonify all these
frequencies you just go
wait what now what do i do with this and
i think
the the way that one has to look at this
is that in the same way that if anybody
has tried to make a
chart or a diagram or a data
visualization
you know that even if you know very well
what it is that you're trying to
visualize
you have to really put the psychology of
yourself
and your audience into your mind if
you're going to make an effective
visualization
and the same is true with sonification
it's really just not a it's not a matter
of just going
let's sonify it okay there it is it's
sonified now we know what jackson
pollock
sounds like or now we know what the
coronavirus sounds like or now we know
what a spiderweb
sounds like what you have gotten is the
same way that if you just like
hit you know the graphic
button on an excel spreadsheet you get
something and you go like well wait i
can't use that that doesn't
show what i find interesting about this
or it doesn't it doesn't make evident
anything that i'm trying to learn from
this and you have to
it's not that you are going to change
the data but you have to change the way
that you
present the data so in this case
what we really were thinking about was
how to just create
a a way i guess you know um
it all goes back to this movie fantastic
voyage that i saw when i was eight years
old
where people shrunk down to the size of
blood of blood uh corpuscles and were
put into a little
spaceship that went into the body and
zoomed around and i thought
well that would be you know if if you
really want to think like a spider you
got to think about how a spider sees the
world and we can't do that a spider has
eight eyes they have no ears
so even there is no hearing of the
spider web because
we can hear the way a microphone would
hear it which is what tomas did
we can hear the way a human ear might
hear it if you put it into human range
but
there's a subjectivity involved in any
sensory
apparatus and in any interpretation of
sensory apparatus and so
inevitably that component comes into
play
that's fascinating i think that's quite
a nice
note to uh to end on unless anybody has
anything
um specific to add okay so
i will thank everybody once again
crowder uh uh and uh
here is a huge amount of support uh
behind the scenes
um and also to roger michael um and
our other collaborators who have done
and done an awful lot of work over the
last few months to uh
to put all this together and start this
adventure
thank you so much and good evening